le père noël a lancé sa tournée pas
encore celle des cadeaux mais celle des
marchés dans son parcours le marché des
voisins solidaires à saint cyr l'école
organisée par une quinzaine de voisins
du quartier charles renard on a joué bas
la solidarité des gens c est ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un petit coup de main
une heure de votre temps juste quelque
chose pour ba qu' on puisse avoir tout
est toutes les générations autour de
nous
les commerçants ont joué le jeu aussi
voilà solidaire charcuterie corse
champagne et des cadeaux une centaine
d'artisans et commerçants a répondu à
l'appel comme ceux passionnés qui
travaillent le bois de récup
ce qui m'intéresse réellement c'est
partager ma passion encore une fois
c'est partir du jardin est amenée sur la
table et de faire découvrir aux gens que
les arbres qu'on trouve dans le jardin
horn dans nos forêts une fois qu'on les
ouvre
ils ont plein de couleurs plate forme et
plein de pattern à montigny le
bretonneux la ferme du manet s'est
transformée en eau géantes pour
accueillir les 17 mille visiteurs plus
de 130 exposants s'étaient donné
rendez-vous pour proposer douze bijoux
et autres douceurs
c'est le foie gras de noël programme du
premier de l'or le programme de la fête
de la joie du bonheur
le foie gras du gers pour nous c'est un
rendez vous incontournable
et c'est parce qu'ils mettent en avant
les producteurs de bovins de foie gras
de saucisson
et c'est dans ces le marché des
producteurs encore trois semaines pour
que le père noël puisse compléter les
demandes qui lui sont adressées les
marchés donne des idées pour que le 24
décembre soit sur son 31